all the red shells and mushrooms in the
world wouldn't help a driver who still
has their training license so feel proud
when you wave that checkered flag those
days when Mario Kart used to serve up
first place on a silver platter have
gone the way of the Virtual Boy
now it takes raw skill and stubborn
determination to rise above the madness
and the experience couldn't be better
for it
I earned every one of my victories in
Mario Kart 8 and took great pleasure and
wiping that foolish smile off Donkey
Kong's face turns in Mario Kart 8
backing you to power slide ramps purrs
you to boost off them and performing
tight maneuvers through the many snaking
twists is a difficult endeavor that's
immensely rewarding the feeling of the
ground beneath your tires or hover pads
when you ride up walls and ceilings it's
so tight and immediately you're one with
the road your prize for braving the
challenges loneliness you can stay
safely in first place once you've
mastered the racing lines let everyone
else battle for second
you see those dastardly items that have
been the scourge of my existence in
previous mario karts have had their
impact drastically reduced
oh there are still blue shells that
punish those with talents and lightning
bolts that place a shrinking handicap on
the entire field but their effects
aren't nearly as great as recent entries
if you're smart behind the wheel a mere
shell is little more than a speed bump
so don't be discouraged when you're
struck skill being more important than
items is true rather than you're racing
against the computer or a group of your
friends sure there are times when you're
struck by a couple items at quick
succession but such moments of
profession are rare enough that you
always feel in control
this emphasis on racing ability means
that it's harder to come back once you
fall behind if you find yourself in the
middle of a pack there are so many items
about that your rhythm is constantly
interrupted and there aren't any instant
win items either it takes a lot of
effort to claw yourself back to the top
so my advice is to not fall behind in
the first place Mario karts racing is as
good as the franchise has seen and not
just because you're driving sales are so
much more important than item lock it's
the feeling of rounding corners it's so
diller a ting of gliding through the air
and deftly skirting hazards littering
the ground earning boosts through turns
requires steely concentration the longer
you hold your drift
the faster you shoot out of the turn
it's a tense game of chicken pushing
your rider to his/her or its limit as
great as the racing is in Mario Kart 8
there are a couple head-scratching
features that stand out like sore thumbs
why for instance isn't there clock and
Grand Prix do we really need so many
different kart parts who thought it was
a good idea for the default option after
a race to be view highlight reel oh and
of the 30 playable characters there are
two palace swaps five babies and seven
Koopa kids very boring one last
complaint and this is a biggie
battle mode is pretty terrible instead
of specially-made arenas you choose from
eight of the racing tracks driving
aimlessly around trying to find your
friends is the exact opposite of fun
sure the whole battle mode thing became
past day a few years back but having
everyone fight on racetracks doesn't fix
that all right enough poking holes in
this ridiculous game Mario Kart 8 is an
achievement because it's still as warm
and welcoming as you'd expect but isn't
so desperate to be like that it waters
down the experience for those who don't
need a helping hand and the tracks
demand precise driving with shortcuts
that only the most daring will
consistently reach there are some duds
out there such as toads Turnpike from
Mario Kart 64 but most of the 32 are
worth putting serious time into until
you master their
many turns nintendo has done a fine job
of keeping mario kart relevant how many
franchises have remained in peak form
for more than 20 years
not many I admit that in the early going
yawns it's more mario karts but as I
rose through the ranks and learn the
courses my tone shifted one of
excitements it's more mario karts and
i'm happy nintendo hasn't forgotten what
makes this series so darn fun
Oh